[Music]
[Applause]
just the music calms me down the series
ted lasso on apple tv plus was a
surprise hit last year
jason sudeikis stars as ted lasso he's
an american college football coach with
very little knowledge of soccer
but he's suddenly thrown into the
high-stakes sport when he takes on a job
as a coach
of a mediocre english premier league
team
ted's kindness and enthusiasm slowly win
over the skeptical players
and their fans and this morning we have
a u.s
exclusive a first look at season two
here's the trailer check it out
so you're heavily favored this weekend
do you think this will end your
embarrassing streak of draws lord i've
never been embarrassed about having
streaks in my drawers
you know it's all part of growing up
[Applause]
i got a question for you has a team a
lot of us ever won the whole chimichanga
not for 40 years
oh no you don't come through here that's
fine yeah i got you it's like dukes of
hazards
or y'all probably call it the earls of
risk over here
and i'm very happy to be joined now by
jason sudeikis and brandon hunt
co-creators writers and stars of the
show
brendan plays ted's assistant coach
beard good morning to both of you
i love the show thank you for making it
that's my first comment
second comment is hooray for season two
that's exciting
uh let me go to you first jason we
called it a surprise hit but it's a
really good
show why do you think it resonated
oh gosh i don't know i mean first off
thank you for having us and for your
kind words
up top there but i um i don't know
probably because there's
you know sports and it's colorful
there's nice looking people on it
they're swearing
i don't know it's got a little bit of
everything i agree with you
you're right who knows what you you
based on the character
you based the series off of what had
been a tv commercial
for soccer coverage like five years ago
here in the u.s
and you made it sweeter than that
original character talk about the
process a little bit
well yeah we did we did the first
commercial uh for um
nbc sports back in 2013 and and that
went well like people liked us we got to
do a second one and in doing the second
one having
sort of a past of working at live and
doing recurring characters i
i always sort of you know preferred you
know trying to extend the storyline
versus just hitting the same
you know beats of the same jokes over
and over and in doing so
he got fired at the end of the first
commercial and yet he returned to
america loving
his time his three days in england is
he fell in love with the game of soccer
and so that enthusiasm really unlocked
sort of this you know unwavering
optimism and sort of like
childlike enthusiasm for um you know the
sport and and just life in general i'm
curious that's really what sort of
when you start when you start with a
commercial jason and you're
and you're taking it to a whole tv show
with multiple episodes
what is it in there that convinces you
that you can make that leap
i think it was uh understanding the
character you know uh
you know working with brendan here and
our other buddy joe kelly
you know the three of us just get on
well and and it it's
that sort of um you know when when
one of the three of us makes the other
two laugh we know we're doing
you know something worthwhile and and
it's just one of those things that you
see little boys and girls doing in
you know playgrounds around the world
around the world and so to get paid for
it and have people like it and
you know families watching it together
yeah why wouldn't you want to try that
again and again
so we've got a surprise for you guys
coming up but first i want to get a
coach beard brendan on the record here
on season two what can we expect
um there's gonna be uh soccer players
yeah
all right all right there's gonna be
people of an english nature uh
surrounding them
by the thousands uh who will have very
strong opinions about
what those people are doing and the way
they kick that thing i want to stop you
there because i think you may be giving
too much away will there be two
americans at the center of this
oh who told you leaks
wikileaks out there again
i love brendan as your character is
is tops in my book because he's the
brains behind
the heart you know it's hard soul brains
jason
full disclosure here you had me at uh
several of your movies but i have to
tell you we're gonna
we're gonna break some news here and i
know you all know but our audience
doesn't
and that's because you guys have won a
major award a peabody folks
a peabody awards cited for inspiring
models
of kindness one of the friends one of
your friends recorded a little special
greeting for you take a look
or listen i just wanted to uh to take
time out here while i was strolling
through the
palatial grounds of my backyard to give
a heartfelt
congratulations to jason zedekis bill
lawrence
on ted lasso and the fact that you are
receiving a peabody award
congratulations to everyone
on the cast and crew to apple uh
you guys really did it you created a
very special show that was not only
funny
but poignant and came at a time
when we really needed to laugh hey get
out of my backyard okay
i gotta go is that george w bush
your good buddy wolf daryl there i mean
what's your reaction
i i mean that's very kind of him to do
that uh
yeah i i mean it's overwhelming it's
it's it's really something else
um very flattered uh flattered for the
for the reasons by which they you know
bestowed us with this honor and uh and
yeah i
i don't blame that homeowner for being
furious about will's
tramping on their clearly well-manicured
lawn i know you guys are a huge soccer
fan
just quickly i mean how is the soccer
community really embraced the show
oh it's been i mean surprisingly well
great actually from like yeah go ahead
brennan yeah
from like you know english coaches or
coaches in england like jurgen klopp and
american players like alex morgan who
did a ted lasso goal celebration in a
match about a month ago
um it's been i mean they're all
acknowledging something we know to be
true which is
we don't really do soccer accurately
particularly on the show um
so for them to like it anyway we really
appreciate that
well look we uh we really appreciate the
show uh thank you for making season one
i'm very excited about season two your
description of it brendan was fantastic
uh really the excitement levels are
through the roof uh jason sudeikis
brendan hunt we appreciate it season two
10 lasso premieres on apple tv plus
on the 23rd of july we'll be right back